oui et nous restons du côté d'el en
cours pour aller à france miniature donc
marianne et diers dit nous le parc a
rouvert week-end dernier quelles sont
les nouveautés je crois qu'on peut
compter 117 monument plus un mais lequel
plus un qui est en cours de finition qui
n'est pas encore présent sur le parc ce
sera une gigantesque cité de carcassonne
puisque cette forteresse va venir
s'installer sur plus de 18 mètres de
long donc on va avoir une très très
grande mise en scène avec un respect de
tout le dénivelé de toute l'installation
de la double muraille qui caractérise
cette ville fortifiée
non non mon magnéto 1 30e ça sera une
maquette au 1 30e c'est pour ça qu'elle
sera du coup énorme et qu'elle nous
contraint à réaménager un petit peu le
sud de la france puisque le parc à la
forme de la carte de france et que à cet
endroit là on a quelques moulins ou
châteaux cathares qui va falloir des
débuts débloquer un petit peu donc un
gros chantier qui va qui a démarré et
qui va se prolonger jusque fin mai
normalement fin mai l'ensemble de la
mise en scène sera terminée les choix de
la cité de carcassonne vous avez fait ce
choix alors le choix de la cité
carcassonne et le choix de plein
d'autres monuments la contrainte la
première c'est d'abord de pouvoir
respecter l'implantation de ces
monuments sur notre carte de
géographique et puis également de
représenter ce qui est incontournable
alors soit un monument classé au
patrimoine mondial de l'unesco comme
c'est le cas de celui ci soit pour des
raisons architecturales ou de dattes
hippisme parfois également il ya des
petits villages typiques des ports des
gars il va y avoir une simple la
cathédrale de royan qui est assez
particulière en termes d'architecturé
voilà qui la connaissent en fait on va
choisir des choses qui sont remarquables
dans vous réunissez en vie dans tous les
sens sans voir insisté bon royan alors
qu'en général c'est fait avec la
direction du parc avec effectivement les
gens qui travaillent sur le site qui
entendent aussi ce que les visiteurs
réclamée puisqu'on est aussi sensible
aux attentes de nos visiteurs
donc voilà la cité de carcassonne sera
sera une réponse via nous sommes nous
sommes rendus justement dimanche dernier
sous un magnifique soleil au parc donc
on va regarder en images tout de suite
donc un reportage de valérie auribeau
guillaume quand versailles comme vous ne
l'avez jamais vu ce premier week-end de
mars la france rouvrait ses portes celle
de france miniature à elancourt 117
monument du patrimoine français
reproduit au 1 30e réalisée en résine
pvc ou même enfer pour la tour eiffel
elle émerveille chaque année les deux
cent mille visiteurs quand j'étais tout
petit j'étais venu d'angers de vagues
souvenirs mais je suis né j'ai c'était
bien culturellement spot se balader en
france de découvrir les monuments
historiques ont en france on a envie de
féliciter la france
voyager vraiment parce que je
connaissais certains des sites mais pas
loin de la plupart et on se rend compte
combien ces divers je trouve que c'est
une merveille les les monuments sont
vraiment magnifiques
cette année le parc réserve une
nouveauté de taille c'est la cité
médiévale de carcassonne qui va devenir
une des plus grandes maquettes du parc
150 m² et pour tout à fait bien
représenté cette cité médiévale inscrite
au patrimoine mondial de l'unesco le
chantier a déjà commencé
les remparts devrait être installé pour
avril et les travaux terminés femme est
coût de la réalisation 80000 euros et si
les monuments font le bonheur des plus
grands les huit attractions font la joie
des plus petits le grand toboggan
la grande balançoires et celle qui
descend et qui montrent à tous et elle
et moi on était là paris est comme un
trait dessus obama j'ai vu les voitures
prochain rendez-vous de france miniature
à ne pas manquer l'atelier chocolat à
pâques et la démonstration d'un parcours
d'agilité équestre en avril ne laissez
pas le train partir sans vous
alors vous proposer également une
animation pendant les vacances alors de
quoi s'agit-il alors pendant les
vacances non loin de la traction qui
évoquait cette petite fille petite
voiture c'est une attraction couvertes
on utilise cet espace couvert pour
accueillir un partenaire qui est
l'office pour les insectes et leur
environnement qui était basé jusqu'il ya
quelques temps à guyancourt et qui
aujourd'hui exerce hors les murs nous
l'accueillons donc à france miniature
pour trois jours cette semaine trois
jours la semaine prochaine vendredi
samedi dimanche tous les après midi les
enfants pourront découvrir
les insectes qui vivent sous nos pieds
pour certains à travers des ateliers qui
vont être proposées par une
entomologiste qui sera là donc chaque
après midi il y aura la possibilité de
fouiller le sol elle va apporter des
terrariums avec tout un tas de choses à
découvrir il ya d'autres insectes qui
seront visibles dans leur terrarium
également des projections et puis on a
préparé un petit jeu de piste un petit
jeu avec des énigmes et des questions
puisque en général le public aime bien
s'amuser à chercher et curieux donc ça
ce sera effectivement pendant ces deux
semaines de vacances les trois jours de
fin de semaine tessa donc les dates 8 9
10 15 16 et 17 c sur très précisément
parfait
peut-être nouvelle pause bas une
nouvelle pousse à vous attendiez après
avoir parlé des oiseaux à la ferme de
gally des insectes aussi du côté de
france miniature on va voir ce que
réserve le musée de la ville est ce
qu'il ya des animaux ou pas vous savez
nous le dire tout à l'heure auparavant
comment occuper vos enfants pendant les
vacances micro-trottoir journée un cas
bientôt 12 ans et donc il est une
semaine chez ses grands-parents et
l'autre semaine on part à la neige elle
est avec son grand père et sa grand mère
et puis après la deuxième semaine son
centre de la terre alors cette semaine
ma petite fille va au multi sports ou
gymnase de coubertin tout l'après midi
voilà de 13h30 à 17h30 j'ai ma fille qui
va la maison de quartier louis jouvet
puis donc là ils ont proposé tout ce
qu'ils activités piscine ben oui c'est
juste à côté de la maison pour petits
non il n'y a pas d'activité maison de
quartier ni centre aéré donc j'ai
s'occupe des activités manuelles de là
bas là non plus il fait beau c'est ans y
est donc malheureusement chez travail et
lui la cie se repose il regarde la télé
lecture piscine
et apprentissage du vélo se balade à
pied ont fait des sorties culturelles
demain au château de breteuil et puis la
bergerie nationale de rambouillet